site director tilda moose was staring
down the barrel of the gun that would
cause the apocalypse and
scp-6000 was pulling back the hammer
typically someone as important as the
site director of site 19 the
foundation's largest containment site
would never be put on a mission as risky
as accompanying mtf sigma 3 aka the
bibliographers right into the heart of
an active anomaly but these were
extraordinary circumstances to say the
least dr moose and the operatives of mtf
sigma 3 fire team chicago entered
brazilian airspace in late december of
the year 2030. below them an ocean of
trees the amazon rainforest known to
some as the lung of the world and the
lung had a cancer known as
scp-6000 director moose could see it on
the horizon beautiful and terrifying
like a huge shimmering scar on the
jungle's canopy it had been identified a
few days earlier via live satellite
imaging opening up like a wound in the
world's largest rainforest and it was
growing swallowing up and affecting
entire areas of land by the kilometer
not wanting to waste any more time the
foundation immediately sent in a recon
team to gather the first intel on this
rapidly developing anomaly once inside
the affected area known to the
foundation as the exclusion zone they
discovered unprecedented phenomena the
flora and fauna of the rainforest had
been altered drastically in the affected
areas trees appeared to be somehow
naturally carved into living bookshelves
their leaves tattooed with words huge
alien birds soared above the forest with
their paper-like wings also covered in
text spotted jaguars with six or even
eight limbs like a freakish
crossbreeding of animal and insect
lopped through the papery thickets and
hunt of word-covered prey every living
creature in the forest had been
transformed by scp-6000
and it was about to get a whole lot
worse if scp-6000's exclusion zone
continued to expand not only with the
anomalous effects prolong but they'd
increase in their intensity mutating
everything scp-6000 touched reaching
further and further across the landscape
the foundation needed to gather all the
intel they possibly could on this
emerging anomaly before it was too late
but time was beginning to run out just
as they began to gain traction the
foundation suddenly lost contact with
the initial reconnaissance team they
seemed to have fallen off the map
vanished this triggered the immediate
deployment of subsequent expeditions
into the scp-6000 exclusion zone when
the bibliographer's first strike team
arrived on the scene of the exclusion
zone's bizarre alien world in search of
the missing reconnaissance team they
found the most strange and damning
discovery yet a creature who would soon
come to be known as scp-6000-a
much like the exclusion zone itself
she was both terrifying and beautiful
half maiden half monster a sleeping
woman with skin covered in scales her
legs replaced by the huge coiling tail
of a python she was reminiscent of the
mythical nagas or gorgons and thankfully
for all the mtf members in attendance
she was already in a sort of unconscious
state when they happened upon her
perhaps even more bizarre than the
creature herself was the question of
what on earth had been going on around
her she was found at the base of a
mutated tree already halfway transformed
into a bookcase there were several large
stones placed in the circle around her
each one covered in thaumaturgic symbols
written in what was presumably human
blood as though some strange ritual had
recently been performed but the most
notable detail of all was the fact that
she was surrounded by 12 corpses though
they remain unidentified to this day
there is one thing about the corpses
that was clear they were all wearing
dark robes it didn't take the
foundation's brightest minds to
calculate the connection figures and
robes performing strange rituals
anomalous creatures everywhere
the sudden appearance of a multitude of
anomalous books and the decidedly
serpentine entity this had to be somehow
related to the serpent's hand an
infamous group of interest that takes a
hard stance on defying the foundation's
secrecy and revealing the truth about
anomalies to the world while still
comatose
scp-6000-a was secured and taken back to
be contained in facility 57 while sigma
3 fire team chicago suited up and
prepared for their first trip into the
exclusion zone among them of course was
site 19 director tilda moose so let's
answer the big question on everyone's
mind right now why send someone as
important as a site director into a
potentially hazardous environment where
an entire reconnaissance team had
already gone missing and the serpent's
hand were believed to still be operating
because nobody at the foundation
understands the serpent's hand quite
like director moose after all in another
life before joining the scp foundation
she worked with them to the foundation
cooperative ex-goi members are worth
their weight in gold and in a situation
like this nobody could possibly be more
valuable than director moose she knew
the way and we mean that literally
all signs pointed to scp-6000 being the
largest and most unstable class w
gateway that the foundation has ever
discovered but you might be more
familiar with the concept of class w
gateways when they're referred to simply
as the ways the entrances into and out
of the wanderers library the legendary
extra dimensional location that exists
as a nexus between various realities
that has become a kind of unofficial
headquarters for the serpent's hand
director moose had used the ways before
to enter and gain access to the
wanderers library back when she was one
of the hands but even she admitted that
she'd never seen anything quite like
scp-6000 when they touched down and
director moose first saw the environment
around them the shelves the books the
pages the text she felt a powerful sense
of deja vu it was just like the library
but something was wrong the way here was
not a standard dimensional doorway it
was more like a kind of open wound and
the wanderers library was spilling out
of it and into our world given the raw
cosmic power of the library it was bound
to twist our world into its own image
not the other way around there was only
one thing to do from here with director
moose leading at the head they would use
this vast new way to travel into the
heart of the wanderers library itself
and search for answers after all the
library is said to contain all knowledge
across the multiverse so presumably it
would grant them the solution they
needed to the scp-6000 dilemma they were
faced with but getting answers from the
library especially if you work for the
scp foundation is easier said than done
as fire team chicago made their way
further into scp-6000 they reached an
area that director moose could at least
recognize as the true wanderers library
the dirt gave way to wood paneling
beneath their feet the air shimmered
like an oil slick mutated trees gave way
to giant empty bookcases like they were
witnessing the birth of a new expansion
as soon as they arrived and began
venturing through the labyrinthian
corridors of the wanderers library the
libraries inhabitants took notice
surprised that the library has some
permanent residence don't be after all
you can hardly have a library without
librarians as only people with
experience like director moose know the
wanders library has an enormous
contingent of creatures known as
librarians and archivists permanently
wandering their halls arranging the
books and protecting the location from
threats threats like fire team chicago
the team had their weapons at the ready
when they first saw the creatures
appearing all around them director moose
noticed a giant red millipede skittering
around the hall past them an archivist
it didn't appear actively threatening
but its presence already was a bad sign
then a feminine hissing voice rang out
through the air it said i see your
intentions be gone something about it
communicated a dark and infinite power
and with that more nightmarish
librarians entered the scene huge
spider-like beings with countless limbs
class 3 librarians began crawling down
the bookcases towards them but there was
something different about these
creatures something even worse they were
wearing the uniform of the
reconnaissance team in fact once upon a
time they were the reconnaissance team
but their stories had taken a drastic
turn since they got involved with
scp-6000
something the rest of the world would
soon be able to relate to just seeing
this terrified moose it wasn't unheard
of for the library to transform people
into librarians but that was typically a
punishment reserved for people who
commit only the gravest offenses against
the anomaly what had caused the
wanderers library to become so actively
aggressive they didn't have time to
think about it because things were
getting worse as the class iii
librarians reached the bottom of the
bookcase they began to give chase
leading to fire team chicago desperately
fleeing the scene but they weren't fast
enough the creatures began to attack
tackling and slaughtering members of the
team the survivors fired back but this
led to even more aggression from the
librarians soon a group of class 2
librarians giant hooded beings wielding
lanterns began to join the chase what
started as a highly organized mission
soon became a massacre the foundation
operatives were hopelessly outnumbered
by the library's legion of obedient
monsters they could not fight and win it
was unlike anything they'd ever seen
before director moose was lucky to
escape with her life and in response to
the newly assessed severity of the
scp-6000 threat a wider barrage of
containment methods known as project
fusilade was initiated this meant making
facility 57 the official containment
site of scp-6000
this also resulted in the deployment of
active arrest warrants put on all active
serpent's hand cells as well as giving
mtf sigma-3 blanket permissions to
aggressively use any means of force
against the wanderers library's growing
aggression but trouble was already
brewing back at facility 57.
scp-6000-a had awakened an attempt to
attack the foundation personnel around
it when it or rather she was safely
recontained director moose volunteered
to interview her first hand she hoped
that the creature might at least have
some information about what was going on
with
scp-6000 when the interrogation began
6000-a referred to director moose as a
jailer the serpent's hand expression for
members of the scp foundation from this
moose could easily recognize that 6000
had once been a member of the hand a
human too but she'd been changed into
her current form by a far more powerful
being the serpent the great entity that
rules the wanderer's library and the
very namesake of the serpent's hand a
being as old as the universe the queen
of all knowledge and a kind of god in
her own right in a sense director moose
had a standing grudge with the serpent
back when she was a member of the hand
moose was thirsty for knowledge she
craved stories but always frustrated by
the fact that they had to end she stole
sacred texts from the archive of the
wanderers library and ensured that she
would never truly be welcome again as
the interview ended 6000 sha promised to
continue looking through the stories of
the library hoping that the answer to
their struggles would perhaps be hidden
within meanwhile as scp-6000 continued
its aggressive expansion through the
amazon mutating and consuming more land
the efforts of project fusilade
subsequently escalated as well in one of
the largest coordinated efforts in
foundation history operation black star
mobile task forces on every continent
conducted a simultaneous raid on every
single known serpent's hand hotspot
worldwide and they found nothing
every single base was empty all over the
world not a single member of the
serpent's hand could be found it was
roundly concluded that they'd all
returned through the world's various
ways into the wanderers library like a
mother ship that was calling them all
home the serpent's hand the only people
who might have known what was coming
were escaping the planet as far as bad
signs go this was probably the worst one
possible the proverbial rats fleeing the
ship and if the library wanted its
servants to leave the earth it stood to
reason that the serpent had something
horrible planned for everyone and
everything left on it not long after
this director moose decided to deliver a
grim statement to the o5 council about
scp-6000 informing them of the gravity
of this new situation i don't know what
precipitated this but if the library's
turned against humanity the situation is
going to be dire it's a completely alien
entity to us we can't even begin to
understand why it is or does the thing
it does how we don't even know if
there's a rhyme or reason to anything
most foundation personnel only know of
the library in the abstract but i and a
handful of others have actually stepped
foot in the shelves and we can tell you
that it is humanity's greatest blessing
and its greatest threat all at the same
time imagine how much history has been
influenced by people getting into the
library and bringing back knowledge they
would otherwise never have had now
imagine if the source of all knowledge
in the universe turns on us i don't see
this story having a happy ending in
spite of her grim prognosis director
moose couldn't give up in fact she was
relieved of her duties as site 19
director in order to pursue the scp-6000
case and subvert the library apocalypse
full-time seeing as it seemed she was
the only high-ranking member of
foundation personnel who truly
understood what was going on she and the
rest of the project fusilade incident
committee scrambled to find ways to
destroy
scp-6000 or at least put a halt to its
rampant growth they sent in legions of
mobile task forces with flame and
heat-based weaponry trying to burn down
all the mutated trees however the trees
showed an almost complete resistance to
this method with burnt matter quickly
regenerating after the fact in an even
more savage act of war against the
wanderers library itself they fired a
high-yield explosive into the mouth of
scp-6000
however the second the bomb passed the
threshold into the library its effects
were immediately nullified these
concerning developments led to moose and
her team finally pulling out the big gun
literally the biggest gun there is the
arteris array a giant satellite mounted
laser cannon only called in for the most
dire situations due to its huge
potential for collateral damage however
when they fired the arrays beamed down
onto scp-6000 at full power it remained
utterly unaffected these were just three
of the 34 different failed attempts by
project fusillade to put an end to the
library's rampage before it could keep
expanding and eventually destroy the
earth in a fit of desperation moose
returned once again to scp-6000-a
hoping she would have more answers they
needed a miracle to stop this thing from
becoming an xk class scenario at first
the imprisoned snake woman was cryptic
instead of giving moose useful
information she told her the true origin
of the serpent's hand they were once a
cult devoted to the serpent herself
warriors on behalf of knowledge
incarnate the modern serpent's hand
which claims to be comparatively secular
is little more than a shadow of what it
used to be but they still perform the
same basic task destroying secrecy and
advancing knowledge as moose's patients
wore thin she asked the snake whether
she had any specific stories about how
the foundation could be at a library
gone mad but the snake told her there
were no such stories she did however
surrender one vital piece of information
saying all the stories i see with the
foundation staring down the end of the
world they have the book burners by
their side i suppose there's something
to say there rivals allying themselves
against a threat greater than either
could imagine smoking ash a fusillade of
fire against a wall of trees
there it was
fusilade the namesake of moose's project
against
scp-6000 which the snake would have no
way of knowing about this was it this
was the one narrative thread that could
lead them to their salvation but there
was one other deal that caught moose's
well-trained eye as well the book
burners better known to the scp
foundation and to you as the global
occult coalition one of the foundation's
most bitter rivals in the field of
combating the strange but this time
would it be worth putting aside their
differences to face the greatest threat
in their shared history could the
foundation and the goc together be the
fusillade that holds back the library's
terrifying advance once and for all
the o5 council held a vote on whether
the foundation should get the goc
involved after much deliberation the
motion was approved by a narrow
three-vote margin an emergency envoy
from the foundation was immediately sent
to goc headquarters in germany to invite
them to become a part of project
fusillade and stop scp-6000 expansion
before it was too late after
comprehending the full scope of the
situation and finally coming to
understand just how incredibly dangerous
scp-6000 was the leaders of the goc
approved this historic high-level
partnership goc physics psyche and
ptolemy division personnel were
transported to facility 57 for briefing
on the developing situation if they were
lucky they weren't too late to stop this
xk class end of the world scenario from
unfolding into completion interestingly
the goc prior to the scp-6000 incident
had actually conducted more successful
raids into the wanderers library than
even the foundation had so it was
natural that soon after they became
officially involved the 05 council and
goc command authorized another mission
into the library with goc strike team
9842 probable cause codenamed harbor in
order to discover more about the
situation from within director moose and
one of her closest associates agent adam
macmillan another former serpent's hand
turned foundation agent would instruct
the team via live video and audio link
supplied with state of the art goc and
foundation equipment the harbor team
entered the exclusion zone they couldn't
help but remark on the extraordinary
sights before them a shimmering
technicolor fantasy filled with trees
halfway transformed into bookcases but
strangely all of the books within them
were utterly blank following the
instructions delivered by moose and
macmillan the harbor team advanced
further until they found an area where
the forest properly converged into the
library itself
much like fire team chicago had been the
harbor strike team was baffled to find
that this new expanding wing of the
library didn't seem to have any books
inside its endless bookcases the team
remained discreet as roving librarians
patrolled the halls and skittered about
high above them security in the
wanderers library had grown
exponentially eventually harbor found
the first book of the new wing a slim
volume entitled simply in progress much
like scp-6000's takeover of the world
outside but before they could relay the
knowledge within the book back to moose
and macmillan the voice of the serpent
herself once again sounded she asked the
two members of the harbor strike team
why they were there and when they
claimed to simply be following orders
from their commanders the all-powerful
knowledge deity accused them of lying
the strike team members trembled in fear
moments later the two operatives were
claimed by the library much like the scp
foundation recon team before them the
signal link between harbor and command
was severed they
were gone the foundation in the goc's
first joint venture against scp-6000 had
been useless but that wasn't the worst
part the library's unprecedented
counter-attack was about to ruin
everything that the two groups have been
trying to achieve over their entire
existence
scp-6000 began putting out radio signals
but it wasn't just 6000 itself
every single abandoned serpent's hand
cell all over the globe suddenly began
transmitting and boosting the signal as
well it was too big and too coordinated
for even the combined efforts of the
foundation and the coalition to get a
handle on the signal was the voice of
the serpent herself hissing the garden
is the serpent's place and a lot of
people heard it governments
organizations and individuals all over
the world picked up the signal and its
ultimate source the amazon rainforest as
millions of people began to turn their
attention to the amazon their eyes were
drawn to one thing scp-6000
and its enormous shimmering oil slick
expanding out over the canopy too big
now for the foundation and the goc to
keep under wraps anymore the internet
blew up with millions of posts and
messages across every platform
imaginable even the foundation's web
crawler was utterly overwhelmed one form
poster said you guys see the pictures
coming out of brazil msn's probably
gonna get a hold of it by tomorrow and
suppress the story but it's insane i
have no clue what the hell is going on
in the amazon but the pictures make it
look like some sort of oil slick it's
kind of beautiful another commented yep
turns out i'm not nuts my friends have
been hearing it on their car radios and
hams too a woman's voice sort of nasally
repeating numbers and coordinates i
think in the words the garden is the
serpent's place
sounds biblical maybe a passphrase of
some sort now here's the kicker if you
look on google earth or anything for the
coordinates everything's fine it doesn't
show anything out of the ordinary but if
you use a back door to get into the
wildlife observation camera scattered
around the cameras went offline
immediately after but i managed to save
this image starting to think i should go
down there this could be big but random
people on the internet were just the tip
of the iceberg it didn't take long for
all the classified information about
scp-6000 to fall into the hands of a
number of mainstream media outlets the
wall street journal ran it with the
headline the amazon anomaly not long
after the guardian released brazil under
lockdown as the efforts of the
foundation and the goc to keep a lid on
things started to look more like a
military coup than a routine quarantine
effort the horrors started to snowball
news about the strange activity in the
amazon led to a massive influx of
tourists and amateur investigators
attempting to gain access while the
foundation and the goc did what they
could to hold people off and provide
amnesics to those who were actually
exposed it wasn't enough the cat was out
of the bag and now any attempts to cover
up what had already been released felt
like just another element of the
conspiracy knowledge was spreading fast
and then trying to cover it up both the
foundation and the goc risked exposing
even their own existences to the public
in the process the serpent's plan had
been working perfectly it seemed but
this was more than a mere compromise of
informational security the increased
global knowledge of scp-6000 seemed to
massively increase its expansion as
though it fed on people's knowledge of
it the exclusion zone grew by a
terrifying six kilometers and the
mutations within its boundaries only
seemed to intensify things that had
gotten so severe that the coalition's
nuclear resources were being considered
as a response to scp-6000's aggression
not long after this director moose's
closest confidant within project
fusillade agent macmillan disappeared
security footage of facility 57 showed
him performing a thaumaturgic ritual
circle similar to the one that had
produced scp-6000-a
the cameras captured an intense flash of
light from the circle and afterwards
macmillan was gone he left a note for
director moose saying sorry tilly i used
to spend weeks amongst the library
shelves perusing everything i could come
across it was otherworldly in the most
literal sense of the word i'm sure you
understand the feeling the difference is
that you couldn't go in you made the
choice between the library and the
foundation when i first entered it was
just a mission i experienced something
amazing something well beyond what i
thought was ever possible i thought it
was a shame that we looked at something
so magnificent and only worried about
how it might hurt us i can see now
that's not the case the librarians are
only hurting people that try to stop the
expansion i have no intention of doing
that this is the end of the story not
the one where we somehow come up with a
silver bullet to fix everything the only
thing i can do is change how i feel
about it i just want to sit amongst the
shelves and see the false stars again i
think this is my happy ending director
moose certainly didn't see it that way
in spite of everything she was still
desperately searching for that elusive
silver bullet the secret to stopping
scp-6000 and reversing the horrific
damage it had already wrought they were
the scp foundation they always found a
solution it was just a matter of looking
harder for it she returned once again to
her last potential resource on the
matter
scp-6000-a that cryptic snake woman
they'd first discovered in the initial
recon missions into scp-6000
in many ways
scp-6000-a echoed the sentiments of
agent macmillan to deny true fate is
futile just this once the foundation had
run out of silver bullets their end was
coming perfect and inevitable and it
will happen at the hands of the library
and the serpent she told director moose
that you don't get to choose how your
stories end only how you perceive the
ending this story she says ends with two
people sitting in a room talking and
they vanish into thin air tired of the
snake woman's cryptic nonsense director
moose decided she was wasting her time
determined she alongside the foundation
and the global occult coalition would
find a way to stop this thing they would
end
scp-6000 reverse the damage it had
caused and save the day
unfortunately this time
they couldn't the entire amazon basin
was quarantined by project fusillade but
it didn't matter
scp-6000 just kept growing and growing
and growing soon after a bm class broken
masquerade scenario transpired meaning
that the foundation and the goc were no
longer able to contain the secrets of
this anomaly as more and more of the
western hemisphere was consumed by
scp-6000 the anomalies object class was
upgraded from ketter to apollyon as goc
command and the o5 council realized that
the ship had officially sailed on its
fight for containment and for the future
of planet earth as the wanderers library
continued to consume more of the planet
in the following days the priorities of
project fusilade shifted focus from
containing scp-6000
to getting as many key figures and
anomalies as possible off of earth or
out of our dimension all population
centers goc bases and foundation sites
were considered lost it was over the
serpent had won one person who didn't
flee with all the others was director
moose with the prognosis being that
scp-6000 would consume the entire world
in the next two weeks moose decided to
go down with the ship spending her last
days on a dying earth with her final
prisoner
scp-6000-a the snake woman tried to
comfort director moose in the face of
the end she told her that all there
really is in life is a collection of
stories one ending is the beginning to
countless others the end of this earth
this foundation would simply unravel
onto more splitting like a thread's end
into infinite narrative possibilities if
moose could only accept this she would
not see this as an ending but as a
wonderful new beginning a possibility
for more stories that's why the library
was making all these new empty bookcases
there would soon be an abundance of new
knowledge to accommodate and fill its
shelves still moose seemed mournful
about what she saw as the end of her
story the end of the world she asked six
thousand dasha whether her attempts to
stop everything had been pointless from
the start if this ending had always been
set in stone six thousand dash a
responded the point was the same thing
that it's ever been to make new stories
where there was once nothing be happy
tilda your story is going to be
remembered forever how do you think till
the moose responded did she say you
think people will read about us or
rather did she ask what if i don't want
news stories we'll give you a moment to
think about it are you ready the answer
is
it doesn't matter because regardless of
what director moose said it would have
ended exactly the same way if this tale
teaches you anything it should be that
you really can't choose your ending you
can only choose how you react to it
director moose looked up and realized
she was no longer inside facility 57 she
was in the wanderers library staring up
at an infinitude of shelves that
contained an expanse of books that were
both boundless and immeasurable she was
surrounded by people and entities of all
shapes and sizes wearing robes browsing
the new collection and she recognized
all of her old foundation friends and
colleagues among them director moose's
story had come to an end but what she
had failed to grasp was that the end
didn't just mean death it meant the
start of something new new worlds new
dimensions new canons new anomalies a
vast infinity of stories and from inside
the wanderers library with everyone
she'd ever known she could enjoy them
all the wanderers library and the
serpent's hand hadn't killed her they
had saved her
this was director moose's happy ending
and also the ending of scp-6000
but what if this wasn't the end what if
instead tilda moose had chosen a third
option and responded to
6000-a's comment about her story being
remembered forever not with a question
but a statement
stories on stories
perhaps if she had answered this way
then she would have been swept away from
the world that was dying around them to
somewhere new and not just one world but
many where she could have the chance to
see a utopian version of earth where
anomalies were a part of everyday life
their powers are part of the fabric of
society
where disease and suffering had become a
thing of the past she may then have seen
alternate versions of her own story
where she remained a member of the
serpent's hand until the very end or
even another where she was a member of
the o5 council these were all stories
running parallel to hers and ours real
yet untouchable all she could do was
watch these realities knowing that she'd
be unable to help or interact with the
people she saw just as
scp-6000-a had only been able to observe
ours but in the end that was okay
because there was always another story
to move on to someone else's story to
become invested in something else
incredible to see
because just like in the wanderers
library
the end of one story only means the
start of so many others
now go check out
scp-5000y the full story compilation and
scp-xk class end of the world scenarios
explain for more scp foundation tales
about the end of the world as we know it
if you can really call it an end that is